hey thoughty2 here nobody can predict
how long humanity has left on this
planet according to climate alarmists
with a latter-day Jun of our kin there
must hurt we have about 10 to 20 years
before humanity is killed off by its own
industrial desires but more rational
science says we have anywhere from fifty
to hundreds of years before the effects
of climate change reached the point of
no return
if however climate change IVA turns out
to be the biggest scam in human history
or technology comes to the rescue and
reverses co2 emissions then we could be
in for a significantly longer stay on
this planet the optimist in me believes
both of these options are much more
likely than what the do mongers are
espousing but climate change isn't the
only threat to our survival over risks
include nuclear war famine an asteroid
strike a deadly disease pandemic or
killer AI robots whatever is the cause
of Earth's demise and whenever it
happens humanity will have hopefully
spread out into space and colonized
other planets over solar systems or over
galaxies and humanity may survive but
back on earth what would happen if
hypothetically every human alive
suddenly disappeared tomorrow and in
millions of years time when the
intergalactic aliens return to explore
the lost place an intelligent species
once called home will they discover any
remnants of human life will they be able
to tell we were here after Nature has
reclaimed everything we know how would
they know that anyone ever lived on this
hunk of rock what is the very last thing
that humanity
behind I will tell you at the end of
this video and the answer is rather
disturbing but first let's walk through
our hypothetical scenario so every human
on the planet has disappeared what would
be the very next thing to disappear well
it would be the noise within seconds
planet Earth will be cloaked at a
spine-chilling
silence globally the two biggest sources
of constant background noise are human
voices and traffic with no human
activity and nobody around to drive
vehicles the constant low frequency
background home.you have grown
accustomed to will stop go to any
isolated expansive Nature Reserve today
and you'll quickly realize that even
with all those animals and birds
it seems blissfully quiet humans are
tremendous noise polluters the next
thing to go will be the great machines
of Industry and energy production that
keeps civilization running within a few
days to a few weeks every means of power
production will shut down coal and
gas-fired power plants will be the first
to go as they would quickly run out of
fuel nuclear reactors on the other hand
are refueled just once every two years
what's after a couple of weeks their
automated computer systems would safely
shut them down to prevent a meltdown we
are long past the chernobyl days when
human activity was the arbiter standing
between a safe shutdown and the meltdown
computer systems have long been in place
to halt reactors before critical
conditions can be reached so even
without a single humans who watch them
the likelihood of a nuclear disaster in
modern reactors is actually somewhat low
although there are a number of older
nuclear power plants dotted around the
globe that certainly would fail and
release toxic radiation into the
atmosphere
there could be enough to induce a
nuclear winter even wind farms would
grind to a halt due to a lack of
lubricant after a few months and solar
panels would eventually collect too much
dust and debris
on their surfaces to functional fairly
quickly planet earth would go dock and
be instantly thrown back into the Stone
Age
within the first two months the pets
that are able to escape their abodes and
avoid starvation would become feral
meanwhile wild animals would gain the
courage to enter and reclaim our cities
they would now be the Masters next to
reclaim cities would be Mother Nature
within as little as five years two great
cities of the world Tokyo London New
York would be consumed by plants ivy and
moss would scale the tallest skyscrapers
whilst down below the sidewalks and
roads would be torn apart by weeds and
trees pushing their way through the
cracks
within 25 years desert cities like Dubai
and Las Vegas will be encased in a
mountain of sand in the immediate
decades after our disappearance the
cities and great mega structures that
stand as monoliths of human trade
industry and art would begin to crumble
due to a lack of general maintenance
weather erosion and plants winding their
way through water and metal even the
sturdiest man-made structures would
eventually give
within 300 years most of Earth's
suspension bridges will collapse and
crash into a watery tube after 700 years
many brick and wood buildings
specifically the millions of square
miles of suburbs would be consumed by
nature and begin to rots crumble and
fall the steel and glass which makes up
most of our mega cities would wear a
little better alone consumed by nature
and now home to a menagerie of wild
animals it would be roughly 7,000 to
10,000 years before they collapse into a
heap of dust cities like Singapore would
stand for thousands of years as an eerie
natural theme park a Museum of lost
civilization stone buildings would last
for a few millennia - stone is one of
the least reactive building substances
so it has a tendency to endure for a
long long time that's why we still have
Roman architecture to marvel at 2,000
years later after 50,000 years if aliens
visited earth there would be no visible
signs that intelligent species ever
lived here mother nature would have
returned the earth almost entirely to
its pre human state but there is one
man-made structure that would still
stand millions of years after all traces
of humanity have long vanquished into
the soil can you guess what it is no
it's not not food services it is that of
a great tourist attraction Mount
Rushmore Rushmore is carved out of
granite the second hardest naturally
occurring material on earth after
diamond granite is also extremely stable
and largely unreactive with the mountain
reaching over 1,700 meters tall water
erosion is unlikely to be an issue and
being located in one of the most
landlocked locations in the United
States the moisture in the air contains
very little salt from the ocean here so
what wind erosion there is is extremely
gentle all of these factors means that
Mount Rushmore our roads at a rate of
one inch
10,000 years after 1 million years there
will be a slight loss of definition to
the famous faces but it's estimated to
be at least 7.2 million years before the
presidents are no longer recognizable
yet after all this time you would still
be able to make out the basic round
shapes of their heads that's incredible
but fast-forward to 10 million years
after humans quit planet Earth and there
will be no visible signs of our
civilization all books and records of
thousands of years of human endeavor
will be long gone by this point the
unrelenting force of entropy will have
taken its cruel toll and the once
ordered hive of humanity will have
disintegrated into a chaotic maelstrom
of natural obsolescence there will be
zero evidence of our story or will err
perhaps there is one thing that we will
leave behind if you want to know what
humanity will leave behind well there is
only one thing that will always be here
a permanent ring we have carved into our
planets tree trunk there is one and only
one human creation that Mother Nature
can never entirely get rid of plastic
you may have heard that plus it can take
hundreds or even thousands of years to
decompose but that's not the full story
decomposition is defined as microbial
organisms feeding on a material and thus
breaking it down and through enzymatic
action transforming it into another
substance in other words what we observe
as Rossing the issue with plastic is
that unlike almost every other substance
microorganisms don't feed on it they
simply don't recognize it as food what
if I leave a plastic bag outside it
won't still be in one piece in ten years
time never mind a few million years true
but when plastic breaks down
Tiz it's actually decomposing at least
not in the way that's the commonly
accepted scientific definition of
decomposition describes plastic simply
breaks down into smaller and smaller
pieces of plastic plastic is created
from polymers synthetically derived from
oil sure plastic starts life is a
natural substance but by the end there
is nothing natural about it unlike an
apple or a piece of wood in millions of
years a plastic water bottle left
somewhere in the wilderness will still
exist as plastic it will just be in
millions of tiny plastic pieces and
distributed over hundreds potentially
thousands of miles some pieces will be
in the soil some in the ocean but many
will have embedded themselves
permanently into Earth's rock layer this
means that in millions of years
aliens will find a planet with no
immediate trace of human civilization
but when they dig a little deeper
perhaps by mining and examining rocks
they will find something odd they will
discover that the entire planet is
coated for seamless layer of plastic
because Sheeran's have already created
enough plastic to coat the earth many
times like a disturbing but telling mark
eternally edged into the planets long
historic rock record this plastic layer
by that point in time will be many miles
under the Earth's surface but it will be
there a sad but perpetually present
monolith to homosapians brief brief
existence that is unless scientists are
successful in developing microorganisms
that can digest plastic decomposing it
properly which is exactly what some
laboratories are currently doing but in
this scenario we are presuming that
humans disappeared tomorrow before such
an invention but don't get downbeat
because I have full and I think
justified confidence but this is not the
future of humankind
plastic uses a short-term issue that
will hopefully be solved very soon by a
raft of competing technological advances
of which there are many in the pipeline
and thus for our survival who knows we
may still be inhabiting the planet in
some form in ten million years if not
many many other planets - thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please consider supporting me on patreon
using the link in the description it
really really helped me to continue to
make these videos also I've just
launched my first book stick if luck in
it a thousand years of bizarre history
from Britain and beyond
if you would like to get your hands on a
first edition signed copy then head on
over to unbound publishing the links in
the description thank you